another shirt sleeve kind of day once  you get through the morning hours now  it's a little cool this morning  beautiful sunshine though and you know  mercedes talking about daylight saving  time that sunrise was right around 6 a.m  but you know by the time we get to  sunday we're springing forward which  moves our clocks ahead one hour sunrise  coming an hour later but we get to enjoy  that daylight lingering at the end of  the day a little longer lots of 40s  around town this morning 37 out at red  rock i just adjusted the numbers they  haven't moved all that much in the last  hour seven hills down to 40 aliante at  41 summerlin at 45. 36 up there at kyle  canyon we've had some breezy winds  through the mountains and the higher  reaches of the mountains the elevations  up there have been even getting some  stronger winds third